now you've probably heard of the vagus
nerve and the importance of it and
there's all sorts of videos on it there
are certain types of therapy that people
do for the vagus nerve but I think in
this video it's going to be very
important for you to understand the
number one reason why
your vagus nerve might not be working as
well as in a very important function of
the vagus nerve that you also might not
be aware of which is the production of
hydrochloric acid the acid in your
stomach is regulated by the tone of your
vagus nerve so this leads to a huge
chain of a lot of bad things that can
happen to your digestion but if you know
the Simplicity of how to fix it boy you
can turn things around real quick and
improve a lot of digestive problems okay
all right so what is the main
neurotransmitter involved in the vagus
nerve
acetylcholine and acetylcholine needs
vitamin B1 okay very very important and
V1 is a very common deficiency with so
many people because they're doing too
many carbohydrates they're going through
too much stress they might drink a lot
of coffee or tea there's a whole series
of reasons why you might be deficient in
B1 if you don't have enough B1 that
vagus nerve cannot make the hydrochloric
acid that you need and so just hear me
out on what happens when you don't have
enough hydrochloric acid now there's
other reasons why you might not have
hydrochloric acid let's say you're
getting older or you take an antacid or
you're on antibiotics or you don't have
enough salt in your diet regardless of
the cause that hydrochloric acid is very
very very important it should be between
one and three extremely acidic if it's
not the correct pH the valve in the top
of the stomach won't close so you're
going to get acid reflux you're going to
get GERD you're going to have heartburn
okay that's number one
and you may have also the hoarseness in
the throat as well because of the acid
and enzymes that are leaking up or
regurgitating up into your esophagus
literally dissolving nutrition you can't
digest protein too well so the protein
you eat doesn't break down into amino
acids and that can increase your risk of
getting allergies and give you bloating
and constipation and by the way a really
good remedy for constipation is vitamin
B1 why because it not only increases the
digestion because it increases acid in
your stomach it also increases something
called peristalsis or the pumping action
of your colon so without this
hydrochloric acid you don't digest
protein you don't absorb minerals like
iron like calcium like magnesium like
potassium so you become anemic you also
are more susceptible to getting H pylori
right which then can create gastritis or
an ulcer
just as a side note if you have H pylori
a really good remedy is sulfurophane
okay and it just what happens that
software thing is in cabbage it's in
broccoli Sprouts it's not a lot of the
cruciferous vegetables the other thing
you're at risk for when you don't have
enough stomach acid is stomach cancer as
well as an increase in pathogens going
right through the stomach into the small
intestine and what happens next is you
start to get microbes in the small
intestine you shouldn't have a lot of
bacteria and because then you get this
thing called small intestinal bacterial
overgrowth
and then those microbes compete for food
so they start stealing nutrition and you
have a lot of bloating and gas and the
more fiber you eat the worse it is
because you're getting this abnormal
fermentation and then the more
probiotics you have the worse things get
and this is all because you don't have
that acid in your stomach to kill out
the microbes
the acid in the stomach also triggers
the release of bile the bile also helps
to act as a detergent to kill off
microbes in the small intestine that's
why the only part of the small intestine
that can help you reabsorb these bile
salts it's the very last part before it
goes into the large intestine it gets
absorbed and it gets recycled so you
recycle like 95 of your bile salts
because you need them as a detergent to
kill up microbes in the small intestine
as well as extract nutrients from your
food which you're not going to do if you
don't have enough bile because you don't
have enough acid because you don't have
enough B1 so now all this undigested
material ends up in the large intestine
boy there's a lot of issues that occur
there because your large intestine is
not necessarily meant for a complete
digestion of proteins and these other
things ninety percent of all your
digestion occurs in the small intestine
the large intestine is more for
fermentation of fiber or recycling of
these electrolytes so you can imagine
that the now the large intestine is
stuck with this big job of trying to
digest things and you just have all
sorts of digestive problems you might
have gas diarrhea constipation and then
you might get inflammation okay that
then leads to leaky gut and then you
have immune problems and allergies and
food allergies
and potentially autoimmune problems but
other than that you'll be perfectly fine
except for anything going on negative in
your digestive system instantly
translates to problems up in your head
okay because there's something called
the gut brain access and if you're not
digesting if you have these problems in
the gut you're going to also have
cognitive problems and mood issues and
not feel good mentally take Natural B1
immediately you can get it from
nutritional yeast you can find a
supplement that has natural B1 but that
would be the first thing to do and that
just might solve all of these problems
okay now chances are you might be very
depleted with this hydrochloric acid so
you're probably going to have to
replenish that because of how long this
has gone on
so the way to do that is start to take
betaine hydrochloride okay and you can
get that in the supplement and you take
don't just take one take like at least
five and then you want to increase it up
to maybe even ten right for a meal
because
you might need a lot to create this
effect and you might have to take it for
a period of time to build up the acid in
your stomach there's some other things
you might want to take if you have
gastritis or an ulcer like zinc
carnosine if you have sibo small
intestinal bacterial overgrowth you
might want to add garlic to the mix and
if you have inflammation in the lower
part of your gut you may need to do a
carnivore for a while because fiber from
vegetables
won't work I only talked about one
purpose of vitamin B1 to increase the
the tone of the vagus nerve that B1 does
a lot more and if you have not seen my
video that I did at one of my Summits
okay
I put that up right here check it out